alex cobb our go-to scooby well he's got
to use that fast for my go-to for alex
to be successful in his debut as an
angel tonight on the bump here at the
big
split-fingered fastball he got to it and
dives down and in down goes anderson
eaton sends this into center field nice
job by adam eaton to work it late in the
count and on pitch number six
service single to center lancelin going
to the mound last year 63 is era 332
more strikeouts in innings pitch which
is good he doesn't walk many people and
left-handers didn't do much with him it
wasn't base hit left field third hit of
the season for fletcher in as many games
struck him out a buzzing fastball
upstairs lance lin and his first white
sox strikeout that's strike three it's a
cutter on the outside half
and that's not even the outside corner
that was the outer half of the plate
the first time in major league history
that
a player making his first major league
start went 5-5
saw the breaking ball the whole way and
fouled it off 1-2 on mercedes sometimes
you gotta get lucky if you hang a
curveball which cobb did
sometimes it hangs
higher
than the hitter wants it to hang
because if that one rolls a little bit
more mercedes hits it awfully hard
mercedes turns on it down the left field
line did he yes he did
the fun never stops with number 73
your mean mercedes bring him home
come on
okay so you ask what you do for an
encore the one thing he didn't do last
night was hit the ball out of the
ballpark so there it is first major
league home run his fifth run batted in
you setting up to give yourself a better
shot to make a play like that
a little roller out in front of the
plate
would be proud of that one
david fletcher four hits on the season
now
i think we all be proud of that one if
we were playing golf be able to get that
to spin and stop like that at the green
61 pitches so far for lanceland 46
fastballs a mile high
and of course tim anderson will catch it
you know what he'd catch it if it was
underneath the halo but it's called off
he should have caught it they should
have let him catch at the halo score run
and it's bouncing around like little
league baseball brendon moves up to
second oh my
anderson went hundreds of feet earlier
to make a spectacular play he was
underneath the baseball
and the center fielder robert called him
off and dropped it
bouncing ball base hit left field here
comes rendon
vaughan is up with it he'll hit the
cutoff man the halos take the lead walsh
with his first base hit and rbi of this
season
one and two from cobb
mercedes up the middle he is seven for
seven to open the year
i gave you the play i gave you the movie
rights and you could have gone yes of
course he's gonna get seven for seven
i'll take the option now
[Applause]
it's
well i think they're probably if you're
if you're joe madden you're thinking
about number one where's this guy been
in number two how in the world do you
get him out yeah where can we send him
back to
what are we going to throw him next so
the next batter is luis robert two on
first and second with
one out here's the pitch and that's a
shot in the left field and that is
likely going to tie the game up just
getting to it is upton by the time he
fires it back it will go to third base
the runner from second will score zach
collins
and that's an rbi hit for luis robert
well he
gave away a run
last inning and now he
drives in a run to tie up the game
ohtani
line drive base hit right field pulled
his hands in he's hit a couple out there
that have big time top spin on him
oh wow
top of the zone see you later two gone
here comes tony at 99 and he doesn't
care about 37 straight at 100 pitches
what he cares about is
retiring walsh in a tie game and he
realizes that walsh has hit the ball
hard twice against lynn
the 11th overall pick
on a tennessee
garrett crochet and then suddenly he
appeared in a white sox jersey in
cincinnati late
in the 2020 season
and stormed
into the white sox bullpen
he struck him out there goes to bat and
there goes the inning and there goes the
neighborhood
garrett crochet vanquishes walsh and
turns him into a bronze medalist in the
javelin
collins hits it hard right hand side and
through that's a base hit and so zach
collins you said it he hit a laser first
time through got an out for his troubles
and now two on nobody out
for your mean mercedes you were thinking
about it musically all night last night
and he unloads to left center field this
is number eight and it takes a big old
bounce your mean mercedes send them to
the all-star game
outrageous what he's done this is
absolutely
hollywood golden
ridiculous for your mean mercedes
well you might want to forget about the
all-star game and just send them to the
hall of fame because he's doing things
that are absolutely ridiculous
your main mercedes eight for eight to
open the season
in the air center field the streak will
end here mike trout makes the catch
and your mean mercedes
will always have
this standing ovation from some angel
fans and will always have eight straight
hits
to begin the 2021
season it is his first
out made since august 2nd
of 2020.
pretty amazing run tony larussa comes up
gives him a hand tony hasn't seen
anything like that
[Applause]
that's a either swing by rendon cinco 93
just pulled the hands in
been on three times tonight first hit
though
walsh out front drives it down the line
fairball into the corner it goes anthony
rendon is being sent on around the relay
no relay we're tied on true ripple
what a game for walsh
as he pounds his hand into his glove
encouraging his teammates here is justin
upton
up high fly ball left field toward the
wall
and jay up going uptown
looking for that pitch inner half
knowing he's going to be pinched inside
and he lifts it out of the ballpark
two-run home run halo's up now
five to three
[Music]
the
a one-ohm ball down to a knee bobbles
recovers
got him
the angels
are two and one to open up the 21 season
what a game this was it's a very good
opponent they're playing in the white
sox a devastating bullpen but able to
come back junior garrett picking up the
w tonight for the halos nice job behind
to play by kurt suzuki but jay up with
the go ahead two run home run the
difference maker jared walsh a big game
as well alex cobb threw the ball
exceptional six very good innings to
start the game a lot of fun this game
there and i'll tell you what this is
some energy this is the third game of
the season it's a lot of fun already